He just very clearly tells the truth far more than Destiny does.
Uh, he also apparently is like a creepy child trafficker, which
sucks. I wish Destiny could meet the bar of being more honest
than a creepy child trafficker.
I was going to do the Willie stuff. I just thought there was
like some there was like a Willie tweet that came out.
I I probably just have to cover it cuz it it goes back to some
stuff I talked about on stream. You guys remember? I'm also I'm
just about done with this. I think I'm not sure how much more
I care about uh the Cricut Con stuff. I'm ready to move on to
something else at this point, but I'll probably switch over to
this Willie stuff cuz it's just it's very very funny to me.
Um in in a very in a general sense. When Willie did his like
video on Destiny, I was like, "Oh, he's just doing this he's
doing this to like distance himself cuz he's panicking after
that conversation, but he doesn't understand like why he changes
his positions. He just has like these emotions and he talks to
like Nicholas and then he goes and does something. He doesn't
like know what he's talking about almost ever. Is Willie back
on the scene? Yeah, Willie came back and started typing about
stuff again and it's I just it was very funny seeing his tweets
about this. Okay.
Is Willie back in Destiny's arms? Well, I wouldn't say that.
I'm just laughing that like
he sort of got by himself and he just doesn't he doesn't believe
in himself at all. Right. I guarantee what happened was he showed
those messages to Nicholas Dioro who has an internal monologue.
Nicholas said, "Yeah, he's pretty clearly like saying he retained
that and it's pretty clearly child. That's pretty crazy." And
Willie was like, "Oh, then I should probably call the cops."
But he didn't know why. I I don't think he had a good idea of
why those DMs were bad
himself. He had to like show somebody and get given confidence.
And when
when Destiny says like, "Oh, this proves that like I'm innocent."
Even though it makes no sense, the way he says it makes no sense.
Lily just goes, "Oh, right. Uh, wait, he must be innocent." Because
this his like center of the universe, his his idea of what's
true is what Destiny
It's It's just very funny. I think he's starting to feel bad
about doxing Rose. I mean, he probably should feel bad. It was
It was like a goofy thing. I was like, "Dude, it's just this
guy's going crazy. This guy's going insane."
I couldn't believe he threw that up. him and I think was it Ethan
Klein, a whole bunch of people threw that [__] up.
I didn't, by the way, I watched the I think the Willie video,
but I didn't I whenever I was posting something of my own, I
didn't cover any of that [__] right? I was just like
I left it all where it was originally posted. The one thing I
did cover, by the way, while redacting stuff was Destiny's doxing
of Rose, posting a bunch of her unique, personally identifiable
information publicly and then trying to get Kiwi Farms to go
and look at it and use it to dox her when he did that. And then
he bragged about doing that. I covered that while censoring the
actual information.
But now I notice people on Twitter have started blaming me for
doxing Rose. And it's like, wait, how does a DJer decide that
I doxed Rose
when Destiny bragged about helping Kiwi Farms find her?
I don't
Oh, that was the other thing. Yeah, the DG shirt. Hold on. I
think I might skip off of this. I just
honestly wasn't that focused on it. Anyway, it was it was a little
goofy. Okay, let me go find these two tweets. Let me go find
them. Let me go find them. Where's the first one? I don't know.
Do I have these in the right order? I think I do. Hold on. I
think it's just this one. Okay,
so this was the original one. Willie Mack needlessly docked a
ton of PII about Rose that didn't even pertain to her age in
his new video. Red equals censored by me, not Willie. Just want
to further reiterate that there is not a single man in this space
that gives a about any woman in these stories. Literally, how
hard is it to not blast this girl's face in PII and videos that
would get 100k plus views? It's crazy that both Pixie and this
Rose Girl have now had their stories be shoved out into the public
by some incels in the commentary community who are so brain broken
by Destiny that they just lose all sensor care.
what?
[laughter] One, I didn't I was incredibly careful about this.
Quayman was incredibly careful about this, right? We didn't post
stuff about Rose. We would laugh about it, but we didn't post
stuff about Rose. We weren't like posting Rose's docs or anything.
You know, I anything I posted, I censored. And and Destiny himself,
this picture was posted by Destiny, and Destiny taunted Kiwi
Farms with this picture. This is the picture she's censoring
right here. By the way, we should all wonder a little bit how
why why wait. Why does she have DG merch on if she's like totally
trafficked or whatever? If she had no idea. Wait, why does she
have Destiny? Wait, why does she have Destiny merch on? I'm curious
about that. Apparently, there's a really good story here. Maybe.
But this this picture was posted by Destiny. He went like Kiwi
Farms, you're too incompetent to find this person. And then when
they did dox her based on this picture that Destiny posted, he
went, "Why do you guys think I helped them find her?"
That was his proof that he didn't think she was 17 was he's like,
"Why do you think I helped Kiwi Farms dox her?" And somehow DJers
go to my comments pointing this out and go, "Well, you doxed
her though." What?
So remember when when LeB said Destiny, you should go to the
police. He responded, "I have nothing to give them. Remember
the only reason they even found the rose person, this is talking
about Kiwi Farms, was because I posted the pics in chat to bait
them into looking."
Seems pretty stupid to do that if I thought she was 17, huh?
So, the picture that this black cat person is going off
is the actual docs that Destiny posted, the actual like personal
like personally identifiable information posted with a malicious
purpose to taunt Kiwi Farms to look for her. And this person
is virtue signaling about how
I don't know, Willie Max the bad guy. How? But but just wait,
it gets better because actually that's not that's not what she
maintains. Just give it a second. It gets worse than that. Okay,
it gets worse than that. There's one more tweet. What is this
one? New court filings reveal that Destiny never even spoke to
Rose. It was her ex-boyfriend the entire time. Good job to deranged
anti-fan communities for pushing this innocent girl to be doxed,
then blasting her all over the internet. Again, Destiny posted
the picture they used to find her. Right. Destiny is the person
who doxed her. That is doxing. When you post PII, uniquely identifiable
PII with a malicious intent, that is
It's a subset of doxing to not post like the full docs, but it
is doxing.
Another completely manufactured drama at the expense of victims
created by by and for creepy stalkers. So, this is clearly a
defense of Destiny, even though she doesn't want to say that,
right? It's clearly her attempting to defend Destiny. Very funny.
Now,
the very interesting thing about this is
what she's saying is this first party testimony from
from Rose is being relayed by Destiny's lawyer, right? So, apparently
Rose was deposed by Pixie. And in that transcript, apparently
she says, "Somebody impersonated me to talk to Destiny." Right?
Uh, we'll give it a second. Taisa, she says, "Somebody impersonated
me to talk to Destiny." Apparently, that's what Andrew Breler
says. So, we're going to take third party testimony and what
she testified to, right? Third party is in Andrew Breler. But
even if you dis even if you didn't include that, even if you
thought Andrew Bre was a totally reliable, always truthful actor,
this would be first party testimony of her experience, which
apparently DJ cheaters think is respectable and is evidence.
Now, thank God because we've been arguing that the ABMC declaration
is evidence the whole time.
But they're they've reached our position of the ABMC declaration
being evidence. Thank God. Hallelujah. Okay.
Now, we're pretty confident that they don't think it should be
dismissed. Right. Right. Yes. Obviously, it's already a very
stupid Yes, your honor. The the child I received was actually
sent to me by a creepy like trafficker, child trafficker. Uh
the child I procured was from a creepy child trafficker, actually,
not a minor themselves. Get owned. Get owned all my haters. Get
owned. I obtained my child from a creepy
I Okay. I All right. Uh, you know, go off, king. Go off, king.
So, yeah. All of this is insane.
Yeah. So, this is Queman actually gets it correct here. It's
just a claim. It's literally not even It's We don't even know
if it's true, but we do agree that it's evidence. Both Queenman
and I would agree that this is evidence. It should be considered.
It should be, you know, examined at trial. Where's the Willie
tweet on this, though? I need the I need the Willie tweet. Where's
the Willie quote? There's a Willie quote here
Willy Willie says, "I will talk about the new Destiny stuff when
the court case is over." And all the cards are on the table.
If I got stuff wrong, it doesn't do anyone any good to not correct
it. We'll reach out to Destiny for an interview then, too. He's
basically like, "I'm gonna sit back and wait." Willie was completely
correct with everything he said. Nothing said here makes Willie
incorrect. Maybe Willie could argue or you could argue that Willie
shouldn't have posted all of the face docks and stuff without
blurring because he didn't have to. Right. Maybe you could argue
that. I think a lot of us argued that that he was like totally
insane for posting it
But
that's all it is. It's not that Willie was wrong about the child
thing.
He made it very clear what he was asking. Destiny understood.
Destiny does the sweaty emote like saying, "Oh, depends on the
reason you're asking for it." Right? Didn't Destiny claim that
he was call that he called Rose and chatted with her? Yes, he
did claim that, I think. Where's our logs here? They're under
one of these. Just give me a second. Not that one. They'll be
under
this one. Yeah. Uh, no, not that one. This one. This is where
This is where Destiny apologized to Pixie, right? 11:29 2024.
Pixie says, "Hey, is there is there other stuff I have to worry
about getting leaked?" He says, "Oh, there shouldn't be. No,
I'm so sorry. There's literally zero excuse." I'd had phone convos
and stuff with this person. They were fairly close to me. It's
worthless to say it at this point, but I'm super sorry. There's
literally no excuse. I won't say or confirm anything about them.
If there's any particular action or thing I can do, just let
me know. So, what is the allegation? So, is Destiny just lying
back then?
I can tell you I'm pretty confident that Solo said he'd never
talk that Solo said at the time Destiny had never talked to
Right. This guy just the problem with Destiny that really the
biggest problem with like trying to cover his stuff is he just
totally shamelessly lies and his audience is too like completely
and entirely mentally to ever handle the lies. They just take
his word as like the word of God. They're too mentally to ever
like
grapple with truth or anything like that. It's very sad. Uh anyway,
so I I just don't understand. And if anybody wants to disagree
with this, the things I'm saying,
they're welcome to join to call in and explain to me where they
think I'm incorrect on any of this. It's how I see it, right?
They'll never ever join. They know they're wrong. They know that
the way they win is by like not ever directly having a confrontation.
That'll continue to be the way it goes. Okay.
Yeah. I just thought it's just very funny that Willie like Willie
can't stand on business and tell this person to go [__]
themselves because he doesn't actually have the like mental strength
or fortitude to know that he was correct in making his video
to know that he was like in the right. He just he has none of
that. It just doesn't exist for him. So, he like has to come
out. He can't he can't take it any further.
Oh, hold on. Oh, did Rose and Destiny have her voice call? Yeah,
I have recordings of the calls that she made back then, but they
are deep in my chats from her like 2 years ago.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's really interesting cuz I Man, maybe I'm just misremembering.
I This is a long time ago now. This is like a year
So, that's interesting for one thing. That's very interesting.
All right.
And here's the thing about stuff from back here. They'll go,
"Oh, but that guy's that guy's the creepy weird child trafficker.
Why would I believe him?" It's like cuz he has like a infinitely
better track record with telling the truth than Destiny does,
unfortunately.
He just very clearly tells the truth far more than Destiny does.
Uh, he also apparently is like a creepy child trafficker, which
sucks. I wish Destiny could meet the bar of being more honest
than a creepy child sex
Alas, we live in this universe where he is less credible than
that person. So, we just have to deal with that. We have to deal
with the facts as they come in this case. Oh, there was one other
thing here.
There's this. I have to see. I might have something different
than this. Can you trust this now if there's a chance there's
catfishing? Well, I believe the only argument you could possibly
have is that this is the catfish. No.
Isn't the only way this makes any sense at all is if this is
the
How could it possibly make any sense if this is not the catfish?
The counter to this is that he's Wait, you understand that the
he posted is just him with Sunday, right? And he said as much
Solo literally said that is on the record that Solo already said
he was just with Sunday when he sent him the that is like just
factually on the record. Nobody can argue that the thing is is
real.
Yeah, that was just him with Sunday directly, obviously. Okay,
wait, there's one other thing I was going to look at here. We
could pull Tyko a little bit. We've got the legal mindset thing.
We can check that as well.
Oh, I was just I had another thing I was going to pull up here.
What was it? Man, there's like there's like so many little things
I've read here that just like blow my mind completely. Wait,
hold on. Wait, who did he talk to? We can chat if you want and
two uh if you want and to last to text it well while I'm driving.
You want to
last to text in all while I'm at all while I'm So he's not going
to text while he's driving. It's fine. I probably won't understand
it. No, it's complicated. Just too much text. I can't really
call right now, but okay. Later. Yeah. Yeah, it's fine. I don't
know if that maybe that doesn't say anything too specific. Seems
like it seems like they
seems like they might have called.
Now, the the big thing here is you guys have to understand,
while I'm willing to accept that this is evidence, I would say
Rose is significantly incentivized to lie in her deposition to
say that that's not her, to say that she doesn't have any idea
what that's about. Right? We we all acknowledge that that Rose,
if she says that's her, she would be admitting to
transmitting child. So, like it's very obvious to me that she
can't
she can't uh like admit to this
Does that mean it's it's wrong? Does that mean that No, doesn't
mean that. Could be the truth. I don't know. All I'm saying is
all I'm saying is it's very unlikely she'd go to that deposition
and say, "Yeah, I sent Yeah, I sent child to this guy."
This would be weird for her to do. Needs to be evidence of her
claims. Well, I mean, you're probably never going to get evidence
of her claims other than her testimony, right? I don't know what
other evidence there would be. You just got to think about like
her claims are evidence, right? Her testimony is evidence. You
could try to subpoena some records. You try to look into a bunch
of stuff, but a lot of this stuff is evidence. It's just not
proof. You don't know it happened for sure. You don't know which
way it happened for sure.
But if I if I'm balanced, like I have to take if the only evidence
you have of anything is just Rose's word, you probably lean probabilistically
more to her word, right? Admitting to creating or lying under
deposition, I know what I would choose. Yeah. Basically,
have they not caught even caught this solo guy yet? That would
be very funny if they caught the solo guy. I hope the cops are
looking. You would hope the cops are looking. Man, I I look at
this stuff and I'm like, there's no way that this works, right?
There's no way that you could virtue signal on both sides of
like doxing rose, but it seems to be actually happening. It's
like very goofy to me that this could actually happen.
Okay. Anyway, I think uh Ty is ready to come in and talk about
the stuff we talked about. Okay, so he made a couple claims.
We'll write them out. We'll talk to him real quick. Let's see
how it goes.
Hello, Tuska.
Give me a second here.
Give me a second here. One second. >> Yes, take your time.
>> Okay. All right. Uh, what are we doing here? I want
to get a notepad up. Give me a sec.
>> Okay, perfect. I've got my files out. >> Okay.
So, I think the first thing we have to address is that none of
the experts testimony around exploiation had anything to do with
my point around spoliation, right? Like literally, I wasn't looking
at the expert's testimony. I wasn't referencing the expert's
testimony. >> So, when you came and said, "Oh, I'm proving
correct because of the expert's testimony." That was a fundamentally
thing to argue.
>> No. So, my argument was that spoliation was not a factor.
Uh and you argued or uh you were arguing
alongside Queenman. Queman made the much more strong argument
that spoliation did occur, but spoliation being the destruction
or altering of evidence that would affect the case. So, did Quman
argue that anything? Did he argue anything having to do with
>> uh what is it? The He argue anything having to do with
One second. I'm just trying to make this bigger so I can track
it on stream. Okay, good. They argue anything to do with the
experts testimony
because I believe both of our arguments were Destiny deleted.
It didn't create any track record, right? >> Uh yes, exactly.
Which is relevant to the expert's testimony. So the argument
that we had was about whether Destiny deleting his Discord logs
and saving it on a private server like the Hillary's emails kind
of thing whether that saved file is foliation of evidence because
it does obviously you are changing the file you are removing
like metadata or whatever it is a different file but all of the
evidence is there as in like the sender and recipient the time
that it was sent the probably the location data the contents
of the messages, all that sort of is still there. >> Um,
possibly >> depending on how you export it, >> Right.
Yes. Exactly. And so, [music] >> my argument was that spolation
is a positive argument that
there is relevant data. >> Hold on. I do need to just
>> No. Um, the argument would be that he can't be trusted
and that he's broken the chain of custody of the evidence, right?
That he's he's damaged the evidence. And I think that's a positive
>> and then you have to prove that it's >> and so
my argument is by him modifi by him being the only person who
has pulled this data down in a state that's mutable. He has already
expoliated. He has already tampered with the evidence the evidence
is no longer observable by a third party. It's taken to a different
place. The third party does not have a record of or might not
have a record of it. Right? If the third party has a record of
it then we're fine. But if the third party doesn't have a record
of it, now he is the only person with that data. He can add or
remove things as he wishes and he is the person being sued. He
cannot be the only c the only custodian of that data. It is by
definition inadmissible. It is by definition damaged
because he is now himself the only person who can who's handled
that data.
>> Sure. And I will agree with that that you can't prove
that it hasn't been altered. No, I'm telling you that it is by
definition tampered. It is by definition tainted.
>> You wouldn't say you wouldn't say the murder positive
argument. You have to prove that it has been altered in a way
that there is spoiled evidence. >> Okay. So for all digital
forensics forever, you can you can delete whatever you want and
it as long as there's no third party record, right? You you're
just fine. There should be no observable rules. There should
be nothing around this to protect people from Yeah. Listen, if
you can delete it, if you have some time alone with it, you could
delete it and it's there's no nothing there, right? You can there
could be a record of you modifying this, of taking it from a
place where it's observable by a third party, right? So, let's
say it's sitting out on a on uh on some camera somewhere. There's
like a murder weapon for some reason sitting on a camera. There's
evidence of the murderer coming in or sorry, the person accused
of murder coming in, grabbing the the weapon out from under that
camera, doing something with it, and putting it back, right?
and you don't have the and then they wipe the previous camera
footage. So, you don't know what it used to look like at all.
There's no third party record of it. And then they say, "But
there's nothing wrong. Prove that I prove that I touched it.
Prove that I did something to it."
>> Um,
I don't I don't know about that. I mean, I think it's like it's
like taking
>> No, no. Your dash cam records a video. >> Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. No. Don't go to a different No. No. Stop. Stop.
Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop. Stop.
Stop. Explain to me why what I said is incorrect. Do not go to
a different hypothetical. Explain to me what you disagree with
with what I just >> I to be honest, I'm not entirely sure
I followed exactly what the data was. >> There is
there is evidence to be wiped. Yes, >> there is evidence,
right? It is being observed by a third party.
>> You take that evidence and you remove it from that third
party's view. you remove the previous archive of that evidence
from the third party and then you put it back after and say,
"Look, it's totally fine.
Is that okay?" when there was a third party that had that had
a hold of this evidence beforehand. >> I mean, it it really
depends on the evidence you're talking about. >> So, for
instance, let's say I get in a wreck. Uh I'm suing, you know,
defendants's insurance company or whatever, and I have my dash
cam footage. my dash cam is saving in some compressed file type
or whatever and I turn it into an MP4
uh or awav or >> you understand I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna put this >> you alter the data but the evidence is
still there.
>> but hold on now in this hypothetical that dash cam was
streaming. Okay, it was streaming to a third party server where
you did where basically somebody else could access it. It would
be open to getting subpoenaed.
You go back, you delete the dash cam footage,
and then
you produce the dash cam footage to the police. Why did you delete
that case? I I don't think it matters. It's still valid evidence.
>> I don't I mean it. >> So So in these cases forever,
we should allow somebody to mistake. >> Stop. Stop. Stop.
Stop. No, I'm not making the mistake. You are wrong. You're going
to argue right now. Hold on. I'm going to give you your exact
argument. You're going to argue that it's a positive argument.
And I have to show how the evidence has changed from before even
though the record is gone and there is no way to do that. Except
I'm going to tell you that no, the person who is breaking the
chain of custody intentionally,
right, to protect themselves, that person has to prove that they
haven't modified the evidence. >> But that's not how it
works.
>> They have modified the evidence by definition. So in
your case, they could go, "Oh, well, I was just transferring
it over. That's fine." A reasonable person would say, "Okay,
that seems
Do you think a person would think it's reasonable to delete all
the evidence from somewhere where it is public? >> Right.
So, you have both both pieces of that thing. There's no reason
to take it down from the public eye. Right. Is >> I mean,
I think there's it's deleting your Discord messages
is a is a thing that private citizens can do
for no reason. >> You're you could delete your dash cam
footage for no reason. But I'm telling you that there was a record
there that a third party had and I think you shouldn't do it.
By the way, my argument would be that you have every right to
delete that public footage, but you can't do it yourself. You
need to have somebody do it for you so that a record can be created
to show that it's not being with.
>> you agree with me because that is the Hillary's email
hypothetical. Hillary went to a law firm and said, "Hey, I can't
do this myself. Can you please do
No, if I if I remember right, that was the that was the the big
um issue with Hillary's private email server was the fact that
the emails were moved from one place to another. >> Uh
and she got two different issues. There were no criminal charges
filed.
>> No, she didn't. >> Yeah, they were deleted from
the Oh, yeah. Okay, that's that's [music] right. So, with the
Hillary's email thing, there was a lot of government,
>> but you understand why Hillary didn't go and filter
those things down herself, >> Say that again. What was
that? >> You understand why Hillary didn't go >> and
filter those things out herself? You understand that there would
have been a ton of suspicion. People would have wondered why
is the actual person being accused of malfence here modifying
the
>> Yes, for sure. >> Okay. Why do you think that
is? Uh, and so, so your argument is that because Destiny
deleted his own messages and recorded it on his own private hard
drive or whatever. >> I'm going to give you my argument.
You don't have to ask my argument. I'll give you my argument
>> without a law firm having that chain of custody type
of thing. Yes. >> Or any digital forensic service having
that chain of custody. Yes.
>> Right. But I'm arguing that it's a positive argument
that spolation
you have to you have to say that there is evidence that is not
available through discovery uh that would have been available
if not for act uh actions of uh defendant
or or plaintiff. >> Sure. So I think that is a positive
argument given the ABMC declaration that this was there.
Right. I think there is some argument. He doesn't deny knowing
Abby, doesn't deny sending her videos, he denies one small portion.
Do you think a reason? So if you had to bet on balance given
that he deleted the third party record, just listen. on balance.
He deleted the third party record. And there is a woman who not
only says she was sent that video has contemporaneous messages
showing that she was telling friends before it ever was leaked
that those videos existed about those videos, right? And that
she has her own videos that were leaked by Destiny non-consensually
to other people. Do you not believe that on balance you might
think, "Oh, I actually don't trust this guy with that video.
I don't or sorry, I don't trust this guy with that evidence.
Like I actually think he should have maintained a record." I
like I mean in in principle, in theory, yes. However, >> preponderance
of evidence in civil court, right? >> In law, no. >> Preponderance
of evidence in civil court, right? >> Well, okay. So, you're
you're sort of conflating some things. So, the ABMC stuff is
based on an agreement of the evidence that's provided
uh between plaintiff and defendant. um based on disagree on provided
>> uh yeah the disagreement is based on evidence that they
both agree agree with existing. So for instance plaintiff
uh at least has been arguing that the date format was not European.
>> This is nothing to do with ABMC. Why did you just bring
that up?
>> The ABMC
um uh uh
testimony. It wasn't a testimony. It was
deposition. The IBMC deposition um said >> it wasn't a
deposition. It was a It was a It was a statement given under
penalty of perjury. >> Okay. Yeah. >> It was a affidavit.
>> Is that
affidavit? Okay. Yeah. Right. >> Statement. It's not like
a list of >> Okay. I I'm
I might be mixing up terms here, but the ABMC filing says
um that she received this um this video and is a list of DMs
that are
are the defendant argu
short circuit for a second. >> No, you're just totally
wrong. You actually have no idea what you're talking about, but
it's fine. Well, well, I'm going to short circuit your argument
because you're going to take forever to explain it. So, your
argument should probably be something like if you want to just
skip or like stick to the same code that everybody does. Well,
actually, there's no proof that the message existed that her
of her sending the video and that means there's no proof of this.
There's no evidence for it at all. >> Is that what you
wanted to say?
>> No. No, absolutely not. So, >> you're saying something
about timestamps which are not relevant to the IBMC stuff at
all. Not a part of that. Nobody is disputing that >> because
it's relevant to the um apparently the Cardi Cardi statute.
>> Yeah. You don't know what you're talking about. It's
not relevant to anything to do with ABMC. Has to do with Rose.
It's totally different argument. You literally don't know what
you're talking about. And you're here once again embarrassing
yourself in front of all these people having no [__]
idea what you're doing.
>> you're uh this is this is why the testimony in in the
um the uh the hearing
um defendants
uh council asked is there any evidence that the video was sent
after October of 2022? This was the Cardi statute. the Violence
Against Women Act, Reauthorization Act of 2022 took effect in
uh October of 2022 or November
uh of 2022.
Um and they argued that AbbyMC
uh and her affidavit was evidence of this because of the flipping
of the uh times because if you read it in
>> no, Destiny himself has admitted that he didn't know
Abby until like March of 2023. You are foundationally recorded.
You have not read this. You don't know what you're talking about.
You are making things up. You're conflating things. The European
date timestamp thing is from Rose's documents. It's from Rose's
text messages. You don't know what you're talking about. Why
don't you just listen when I tell you >> Okay, I I will
concede I might be conflating things. I might be misremembering.
Um but the time stamp thing was the only evidence that they had
that it was after October of 2022 was the conflation of the time
stamps. Anyway, we're getting off track here. >> True.
The ABMC declaration, as you just said, is more evidence. >> Was
the only evidence that they brought up in the hearing. >> Oh
my god, this guy. So, there are >> I mean, there is no
other
arguments for why Cardi should come into effect. Okay. One is
the ongoing dissemination thing that people think about. Okay,
that might be an argument. Maybe. I think I think they won't
>> a long link for Google Drive. Yeah. >> Yeah. I
I think they won't set that precedent. I don't think so. The
second one is ABMC's testimony, the contemporaneous logs, right?
Saying I was sent these videos, her having contemporaneous logs,
knowing about the existence of these videos, not saying other
people's videos existed, right, that she wouldn't have known
about. Technically, you could probably argue Baby Peach's logs
are also evidence of this, but I don't think they've submitted
them because Baby Peach is absolutely minded by Destiny, just
like Anna was, and he's using her in the same way he used Anna.
But that's fine. So, and then the the third thing from this was
the conflation of the time stamps. So, the conflation of the
time stamps, I never bought that. I don't think that's real.
I think it's basically just ABMC right now. And then arguably
some reference to some other people that like sent Pixie DMs.
I I don't know if they'd keep it going on that though. It is
the ABMC thing right now is what the sub is why or how this would
survive subject matter jurisdiction dismissal. >> Okay,
that's
that's what I said, isn't it? No, that's not what you said.
>> Is it Abby MC is the key witness and it does rely on
this conflation of the time >> No, you didn't listen to
me. >> I I did listen to you. There's also the uh Baby
Peach stuff. Um and >> the conflation of the time stamps
was the third pillar, the third argument they had that was not
the weakest argument. The second argument was ABMC. First argument
was,
oh, ongoing dissemination, ongoing publication or whatever.
>> Oh, right. >> Yeah. So, they were I said as much.
You just weren't listening.
As far as the um motion to dis dismiss, there are only two reasons
to not
uh or only two reasons for the c court to think that they have
subject matter jurisdiction, which is one uh the ongoing dissemination
via the active uh Google Drive link
qualifies or two is that the conflation of
allegedly European timestamps means that it was afteration.
They're just saying they don't they don't recognize the IBMC
declaration. They're doing like a sovereign citizen argument.
I don't recognize your authority. I'm a sovereign citizen. That's
all they're doing. >> This has obviously been the strongest
point for all of this is why they wanted to amend the complaint
to add the ABMC declaration. There are three things. You have
talked about two of them. The IBMC declaration is another one.
Uh what's the what's the the third one?
>> ABMC declaration ongoing dissemination conflation of
time stamps. >> Oh, okay. So,
to be clear, I would like Destiny to go down for all of this.
I just I just don't think that the case >> Why do you say
that when you constantly you constantly come on on stream or
into Discord to try to play like Devil's Advocate? You are advocating
for Destiny. Stop saying, "Oh, I want Destiny go down for this."
And then advocating for Destiny. I don't even care that you advocate.
I love dual are willing to come and humiliate themselves for
not awesome. It's so great. But you are playing devil's advocate.
And who is the devil in this case? >> Well, it's obvious
you constantly advocate for destiny. You constantly advocate
for destiny. I am advocating for not to say [laughter] Destiny's
evil. Although he is. It's just to say you're playing devil's
advocate. You are advocating for Destiny
>> That's fine. I love that. It's free content for me.
Thank you. But you're like, stop. Just don't come on and lie
to me when the only positions you take in the Discord repeatedly
are to defend Destiny. It's okay that you do that. We want people
to take those positions. It's the only position you take every
single time.
>> Just stand on business, bro. That's all we want. Literally,
just stand alone on
>> No, you're wrong. You're you're
>> you're being dishonest. Honestly, >> the only
time you talk to me is when you're trying to do this thing again
and then you come on and you have no idea what you're talking
about and it's very embarrassing for you every single time. >> I
don't have the capacity for embarrassment. Okay, >> I know
you don't. >> which is fantastic for me. It's fine. I can
just come on and mock you for being a total and you will come
back the next week with a totally
assertion and humiliate yourself again. And then I post, you
know, I get to stream on kick, you Riy gets to post a video on
YouTube and we both make money. I love it,
>> you know.
Happy to be here. >> Um, but no, I'm not advocating for
destiny. I just think that your takes on the court case are unreasonable.
And >> so, you just came in. You got completely blown the
[__] out in every way by somebody who just knows
the facts of the case here, >> Hold on. Hold on. No, we've
we've gone way off the foliation argument here, but we went off
onto this tangent that I was not worried about. Okay, >> but
your takes are fairly nuanced. Uh, but when I come on arguing
in favor of Destiny, quote unquote, I'm not arguing on Destiny's
behalf. I would like him to go down. I think he's just That's
for sure. I just think this court case is probably not going
to do it. I think this court case is probably going to be dismissed
or uh adjudicated in his favor through summary judgement. >> I
have no I don't care how this court case is going to go to be
honest with you. I think like I think if I had to guess anything,
Pixie is not going to get basically any money. >> That's
what we've that's the only thing that we've debated on >> or
disagreed on. >> No, it isn't >> regarding the we
just debated on something actually technical about why this is
why this would or wouldn't like survive summary judgement. You
said all of these things are wrong and they're proven wrong and
I said no, they're not. And then I laid out what the three pillars
were that are making it survive Cardi uh being being dismissed
um being dismissed on subject matter jurisdiction grounds on
Cardi, right? Because it's outside of the dates. I gave you the
three reasons it wouldn't be and I said two of them were and
I never really believed either of them. It's obviously the ABMC
declaration that's going to make it survive Cardi. >> I
told you that nobody's actually grappled with it. They basically
just go I'm a sovereign citizen. I don't recognize ABMC's authority
to make
I mean, I think we mostly agreed on all of that. Uh, it's >> No,
you literally told me the conflation of time stamps was from
the ABMC
>> that Yeah, I I'll I'll concede. >> You categorically
didn't understand. You totally misunderstood what the actual
evidence was, what the arguments were. You had no idea, but you
spoke the same with the same level of confidence you always do.
>> I I guess. So, I'm not I'm not super It's It's been
a while. I'm not super familiar with the
um AbbyMC stuff, but I came on to discuss spfoliation, which
is what we uh what we disagreed with earlier. Uh me and you and
>> uh I thought you were more reasonable than Cleman, but
you were also certainly wrong. And the current court filings,
uh the filings from uh
was it today? I think uh the 13th.
Did you want to link those so we can go over them?
>> Uh, I did link them there. It's element. You can see
it in the >> sh just clicked over into something crazy.
What the happened here?
>> Um, it was the link that I gave you in
whatever channel it was that you tagged me in. >> Okay,
sure. Hold on. >> I don't remember which one it was.
This is what this is the Okay, so this is So you're talking about
something here. One second. Mr. Pñena has also retracted his
accusation that Banell engaged in evidence bulliation, paragraphs
7, 17, and 18 of his original declarations. Mr. Pñena asserted
and concluded that Banell's Discord chat export had been tampered
with, that Banell had deleted or altered messages, and therefore
Banell's evidence of the April 2022 transmission of the video
to Rose is not reliable and will require further discovery. In
his amended declaration, Mr. Pñena concludes that his initial
conclusions were incorrect and he admits that the grouping thing
wasn't there. Mr. Pñena now withdraws his claim of evidence tampering
and no longer asserts that Benel manipulated the data demonstrating
the April 2022 transmission of the video to Rose. Plaintiff herself
acknowledges that the paragraphs of her opposition predicated
that the uh of her opposition predicated on those now withdrawn
statements are no longer supported and should be disregarded
by the court. This is from
So this is the amendment of his thing and this is his original
thing. So seven. So hold on. We'll look at the amendment really
quickly.
>> Uh 140 178 I think. >> Seven. So there is no paragraph
7 amendment here that I've seen. Have do you see him amending
paragraph 7 here? I just looked. There does not appear to be
any paragraph 7 amended. Okay. >> ECF number 139.
>> Uh let me find it.
>> So 139 is where Mr. Pina was the expert witness who
alleged exoliation.
>> And filing 139. Gosh, there's so many of
>> Uh 139 response in opposition to motion.
>> Yeah. So, I've got it up on screen here. Can you just
join the presentation? I can navigate it for you.
>> Cuz I I'll show you right away that
um he basically says expoliation here. Maybe for 19. Does he
have is paragraph 19? So it appears he still has other paragraphs
that aren't 17 or 18. The second spoilation issue is noted here,
right? And so there is a second spoilation notice. He he he points
here >> determination of the quote unquote video. This
is paragraph 7 in the defendant's motion to dismiss at 12 paragraph
1. Defendant alleges
blah blah blah video. >> What are you Can you tell me what
you're reading? I could just I can pull this up so much easier.
>> Please do. Can you just tell me what you're trying to
read? >> I've already walked through this. If you just
paid attention to what I was telling you, you would have followed
all of this.
>> 139-1. We're on 139-1. So I I will give you that paragraph
17 and 18 are retracted. Okay.
So now you go down to paragraph will be discussed below. The
evidence relied on by defendants to support the April 9th date
is inconsistent and appears to have been tampered with. >> Yep.
So, I'm going to grant you everything from those paragraphs.
Okay. So, what you said when you came to chat was that the was
that the expert was no longer alleging spoilation of any evidence.
Right. >> So, I'm going to say the expert is clearly still
based on paragraph 19 which has not been amended. Paragraph 19.
The second spoilation issue noted is with exhibit E blah blah
blah blah blah. He continues to allege spoliation.
>> So, you've already lost the argument. It's over. >> Hold
on.
The second foliation issue noted is that exhibit E appears to
have manually transposed content from a Discord chat with screen
name blah. The time >> the time stamps we don't have to
you can read this whole thing.
>> You can read this whole thing >> do not match
the same from the lifts >> the defendant prepared. >> Uh
so this is the evidence where he's
doing some >> I we don't have to even talk about it.
>> we don't even have to talk about it because you came
into the chat. I'll actually just pull your chat up because talking
to you is actually like talking to a wall. I don't want to ask
you what your assertion was. I'll just go find the logs.
Give me a second. >> Sure. Go ahead. >> Look, I I'm
I'm happy to have my opinion changed here. >> No, you're
not. Okay, >> you can assert that, but I feel like your
opinion can't be changed from that. So you saw that he had retracted
one of his spoliation allegations. He'd made two. And you said
he no longer alleges spoilation at all. Yes.
>> Okay. So you agree that he is still alleging spoliation.
>> I would disagree with that. >> Can you demonstrate
that? You say >> I want to know. No, you tell me why you're
disagreeing with it.
because it seems like the the majority of the allegations of
spoliation
uh from 17 or 17 >> he had one allegation with screenshots
>> okay he had one allegation screenshots and he says there's
a second allegation second expoliation issue noted here he's
got two so it's not even the majority
>> paragraph 19 paragraph 20 um yeah paragraph 19 and 20
so it's not the majority at all. It is It is equally
>> Oh, the two Google Drive links that uh Destiny purportedly
sent to both Abby and Pete in the two chat threads are actually
not >> you're going to keep reading this, right? You're
going to keep Hold on. You're going to keep reading this >> and
I'm telling you that that part of the testimony is still there.
That's that's what we're arguing whether that part of the testimony
is still there. I don't care about how reasonable the allegation
is, what he's like actually alleging. I'm not arguing about that
with you cuz you you didn't claim that. You didn't claim this
guy's unreliable. You claimed that he had stopped alleging expoliation,
which is false. Can you admit that that is false? >> Stop
alleging expoliation. >> You claimed that he was no longer
alleging expoliation. I'm telling you, it's very clear that he
is still alleging. Now, the last time I said
>> Yes. Yes. So, before you said no, now you say yes. Okay.
Thank you. That is what the argument was about. >> No,
hold on. You're misrepresenting me a little bit here. >> I'm
not. I literally asked you and then I asked you if he is now
alleging exploation and you said no. So, first you argued the
point. You got blown the out again and now you're trying to change
what your argument was. Why didn't you change what your argument
was before? You tried to say no, I disagree.
>> Hold on. The entire disagreement that we had, me, you,
and Quan,
uh, the other >> this isn't about Queman. about what happened
in chat today. We never once argued about about these modifications.
We never once argued about these modifications being actual expoliation.
>> So if you were just if you were talking about like this
stuff >> because when we argued this hadn't happened yet.
>> No, this had happened.
>> No, we argued me, you and >> this guy is just
lying. This guy is just lying. We literally brought this up and
talked about the need to like hash
No, this was filed two days ago.
I mean, we talked like a week ago. >> Well, I'm talking
about the actual document, the actual testimony from the
>> Yes, we talked about that.
>> And at that point, these paragraphs, uh, the main allegations,
paragraph 17, um, 18 and
the introductory paragraph 7, um, were still alleged. And, >> um,
okay.
And you were uh you were arguing and Queman was arguing. Quuman
was arguing
>> We only ever argued that removing the
>> that being the only person with custody of that evidence
was obviously something that taints the evidence. >> That
that would be a disfiation. And now that he has tainted the evidence,
he should have to produce a record showing that he did not taint
that evidence.
>> That he's not a trustworthy person. That he is the person
accused in this case. and him being the sole custodian of that
evidence is incredibly improper.
>> Yes. And that is part of our disagreement is that um
>> he shouldn't have to produce
like it might not exist a record that >> So again, I'm
just going to explain to you that this world that you're arguing
for is somewhere where people can delete and can modify whatever
digital evidence they want and as long as they're sophisticated
in it a little bit, they get away with a crime. You're perfectly
psyched to live in that world.
>> That I mean
that's the world we live in.
>> I'm just I'm arguing that there was a there was an impartial
record. Intentionally obiscating that impartial record means
you need need to produce now your own record showing when I when
I offiscated this, I did so for my own privacy, but not to destroy
evidence, not to tamper with evidence. Here's proof that this
was done above board. >> Right. Well, okay. So in in this
case, Destiny seems to have deleted all of his Discord messages
and put it on a on his own hard drive or something like that.
So this record doesn't exist. There will never be a record that's
verified a chain of custody or anything like that. So this can't
be produced. >> Uh but your argument is that it should
be produced and my argument is that it's a positive it should
have been considered before deleting evidence
that he almost certainly would have conferred with his legal
team before doing so.
Uh I mean if he's smart I would assume that that's likely. >> Yeah.
So I'm just I'm arguing that probably his legal team there's
no reason they shouldn't know about you know eiscocovery services.
No reason.
And so
one of those
>> during the discovery process the uh plaintiff's council
has conferred with defendants council to figure out if this is
legit or not or if they can if they can poke holes in any of
it. uh and haven't found anything to charge.
>> I'm I'm saying the evidence is tainted. I have no idea
how this is going to affect like they might have already settled
this and just said, "Yeah, there's going to be like negative
inference here with regards to the jury or something."
>> Like they they could have discussed this. The judge
could have like ruled on this somewhere. Although I don't know
if the judge rules in private, maybe not. But maybe at some point
they'll they'll talk about this and like the breaking of that
chain, it's like something that can be decided by the jury, right?
They don't have to even make a decision on it.
There's no requirement to make a decision on it right now as
far as I know on like how that should be how what inference you
should take from from Destiny's actions there. I'm assuming that's
going to come down to the trial
>> Oh, I yeah, I I don't know at all how how that would
>> I don't know either. That would be my assumption. I
do think that if they wanted to file a motion for expoliation,
they would need to do uh what do you call it? they would need
to provide like positive evidence. But I do think there's an
argument for the evidence being tainted and a reason why they
shouldn't trust this. And it's a I think to me what this should
obviously be is it should be it should allow you to get subpoenas
for records from Discord that go back far enough to find all
of this >> Yes. But that was what this this filing was.
Um 139, the declaration of a Jesus pina was essentially to be
used as grounds
for a motion
um to something something spoliation, however that worked. I
don't really know how it works. >> Wait, was it what are
you sure
>> there? I don't I don't think they filed the mo motion
for spiliation.
They didn't file a motion for expiliation, but the declaration
of Jesus Pena. Jesus Pena um was an expert witness and he's the
one who alleged the hash fit. He's he's written I mean he's
this this is 25 pages of mostly boring and understandable but
also some uh sort of technical stuff. This is >> I think
some of I think most of this stuff that's on here I'd say most
of these things
>> I could argue against except for the obvious breaking
of the chain of custody. Like I could argue most of the things
he says here around
um around how the cash stuff works, how like he doesn't talk
about how crawlers work and stuff or he doesn't he doesn't know
that
that crawlers can only see things that are posted somewhere else
and probably that implies another person would have been publishing
things. I could do the extra witness stuff for this. >> Hold
on a second. >> You're you're being awfully kind to me
now. So, I'm I need you to like you gota
>> There is no evidence of spoliation,
right? You would agree with that? >> Wait, there is no
positive evidence of spoliation. I've explained like that
>> and I would call this spoliation because I don't believe
this evidence can be uh like trusted anymore, >> right?
Like if the evidence cannot be if the evidence >> if the
evidence cannot be trusted >> allegation of exfoliation
I mean something that the court would accept.
>> Sure. So here's the thing. Okay. Let's say let's say
somebody let's say somebody's a security
allegations of based on evidence that's
>> Uh I think they wouldn't say so I don't even know when
you when you file a motion to allege spiliation you would need
some evidence of that. that wouldn't be proper. But when when
somebody argues that, hey, Destiny's logs shouldn't be shouldn't
be able to be used as evidence to throw this out of court before
we've had discovery on the third party where he deleted the original
version. I think in terms of getting a dismissal, that shouldn't
be able to happen. You should argue against the dismissal.
>> I feel like that's a different thing
because we're talking about spoliation,
not the case entirely. the spoliation of evidence which you said
that >> I think I think the standard that should be set
for digital evidence this is my this is how I feel about it because
of the ne because of the downside if you don't have it set this
way >> is that >> it doesn't matter what you feel
about it it's the law it's the court there's procedures for this
[__] >> okay I don't know what the motion for
spoliation like says I can only look at the definition of spoliation
and say that this evidence has been spoiled yeah
I don't I don't think spoiled is actually the verb but hold on
spoliated This has been >> evidence has been spoiled. You
think >> so? The action of ruining or destroying something.
So I I believe that this evidence has been ruined by the court,
>> right? I believe this I believe this evidence is ruined.
And I when I talked to you in person, I said morally I believe
this evidence is ruined
>> and I stand on this. Absolutely.
>> Oh, morally >> I told you I told you that legally
I don't know exactly how they handle this with the with the
what do you call it? procedures, right? I told you that
>> technically. Yes, that is true. Yes, you did. You did
hedge for sure. What do you >> That's not a hedge. >> That's
not a hedge. Hold on. That's not a hedge. I didn't have an original
>> to hedge against. >> No. No. You argued pretty
hard that evidence was spoiled, that spoliation did occur. >> Um,
and I said morally >> I said explicitly from the beginning.
I said explicitly. from the beginning that I was not arguing
within the court because I didn't know how you file a motion
for this. I don't know. I said if it was legal or sorry, if it
was illegal, if it was like something they could file a motion
against, then probably they would have filed that
>> Okay. So legally, >> so that was that was that
was the base of my opinion.
>> Expiation legally.
So, what you're trying to do is you're trying to win an argument
you had with Queen instead of actually addressing my arguments
at all because you're getting brutally by me. >> Now, I
understand why that's uncomfortable for you. I totally understand
why that's uncomfortable for you, but I need you to stop and
I need you to accept it. Okay? Thank you.
>> Queen's not here. He can't hurt you right now. You're
talking to me. Stop arguing about what Queen was saying, okay?
Nobody gives a [__] >> You got gaped, bro.
You got gaped. So, again, you've already been declared the In
this conversation, you can't just you can't just say no. You
>> you understand that, right?
>> So, you would agree with me yes or no. Plaintiff cannot
make a positive argument that foliation of evidence has occurred
in this case. >> No, they can't. They can't prove that
somebody deleted a digital record when they don't have access
to any of the devices through where that original record could
have been like restored or sorry, stored. I mean, >> yeah,
obviously if I if I delete
>> if I delete the contents of a notepad on my on my computer,
>> you would argue that I that you couldn't possibly prove
that, right?
>> It's just it's literally it's just obviously true. But
that's that doesn't say anything about like what should be done
about how like evidence in a court case should be hel handled.
It doesn't say anything about like the way things should be.
Like not even close. I mean, I I feel
I feel like it's a little bit dubious that it couldn't be discovered
that you had done that.
>> I don't know. There's a lot of a lot of tools to figure
out what files are deleted or if there's any funny business going
on in the records or whatever. >> You don't think it's
easy to to you don't think it's easy to confound time stamps
for like exports and stuff? >> No,
I do not think that's easy to do. >> No. Okay.
>> You don't think that I could go find a way? You don't
think that I could easily go find a way? I could just Google
it right now. How do I change the created date for a file in
Windows?
>> You don't think that's just mutable data that just like
sits there
>> and can't be discovered by uh opposing council?
I
>> How would it be discovered? Wait, how would it be discovered?
>> Because computers do a lot of [__] and there's
a lot of there's just a lot of evidence. It's sort of like I'm
aware computers do a lot of >> taking the taking the unemployment
rate like if the Bureau of Labor Statistics just says that the
unemploy unemployment rate is different or the GDP is different
than it is like I don't know there's just so many bits of evidence
that you have to fake plausibly or like you know you can murder
somebody as long as you wipe your fingerprints off the gun like
it just doesn't work that way. There's so many different bits
of evidence that can be used to triangulate the truth of the
matter. and find that something's been >> you're hypothesizing
right now about things. What if Okay, what if Destiny just got
rid of his hard drives? What if he What if he he did this thing,
he copied some stuff over and then he just deleted his hard drives?
>> Well, I mean, >> the old hard drives like Sorry,
deleted them, ran magnets over them, threw them
>> That would be uh extremely clear.
Super easy.
>> Wait, hold on. No, no, no, no, no, hold on. No, no,
no, no. All you'd have evidence of is that he deleted something.
You wouldn't know what he deleted. You wouldn't know what happened.
You wouldn't have any positive
>> Yeah, but you'd also say that there were Discord messages
that were available. >> No, no, I'm telling you what if
he copies the Discord messages over somewhere else, right? He
modifies them. He copies just those files over. >> Oh,
this is No, you're >> I'm giving you exactly how this would
work. You just modify them. You'd modify the metadata. You copy
them over to a different hard drive. You'd have none of the artifacts
in the operating system with regards to disk operations or anything,
right? And you get rid of those old hard drives and all you could
ever proof. >> Sounds so simple. Copy over the >> Mhm.
Yeah, for sure. I don't know how to >> Dan has literally
run me through this process how easy this is.
>> Best friend is a security expert.
>> All right.
>> It's Wait, do you think that was
>> I mean, I have >> You think Destiny is incapable
of those things? Not that simple. >> I'm I'm just giving
you a hypothetical. It's not difficult to do, right? It's not
difficult to do. I'm telling you, you are making you are setting
a bar that is very low that people can easily clear to just get
out of like whatever they want. And I'm saying that probably
if you're going to delete evidence from somewhere where it's
sitting,
>> the the bar is that there is evidence
uh or there was evidence that would be useful to the case that
is no longer available if not for action of the
>> Yes. And I'm telling you that the ABMC declaration is
evidence that there could be something there and there should
be a subpoena that goes through and gets these records.
I think I think any
>> any of these methods that you're talking about are probably
provable by plaintiff
>> or at least >> why how
>> It's so easy to do this. No, it's so easy to do this
in like a totally like a totally simple way.
>> You say that. I
don't think that's true. It could be. I don't know. But I definitely
don't think it's that simple. >> Why couldn't the FBI recover
all of Hillary Clinton's emails?
>> This is sort of like uh >> Hold on. Can you answer
that question? Why did the FBI fail to recover all of Hillary
Clinton's emails?
>> I don't know. I don't I don't know enough about the
case to be able to answer that question. >> Well, they
were there. They were stored on a computer. The FBI had access
to that computer. Why couldn't they get it? Why couldn't they
prove that those emails were gone? >> I I just don't know.
I
>> You're enough. You're telling me it's super easy for
the FBI or any forensic like uh tech people to find? >> Why
couldn't they find it with Hillary
>> I just I don't I don't know why they couldn't find it.
I don't know enough about that about the case or about the methods
that they used or I I just I don't know. >> You made a
whole bunch of assumptions. Okay, now that now that I'm trying
to get you to play Pixie's Advocate, suddenly your brain doesn't
work. Isn't that curious? >> No, hold on. That's not I
I'm just saying I don't know the details.
>> I mean, what what is your point? Like >> what
is my point? My point is you constantly come into the discord
to argue this side of the case and then I laugh at you for being
like a Destiny advocate and you go, I don't advocate for Destiny.
And then I'm like, "Oh, could you like provide me some of the
some of the unique brain power you have to hypothesize on why
in this very famous case of deleted evidence on in a digital
setting, why that evidence might not have been discoverable?"
And you're like, "I have no idea." >> Yeah, this is technical
stuff and it also involves uh legal processes with I don't know,
there might have even been military law involved. Like I have
I just I just don't know. The Hillary Clinton's emails case was
very complex. Wait, how would >> I just don't know. >> This
is not relevant. >> It's not complex.
>> The point is uh again,
>> can you
positively argue
>> that there is
uh expoliation? >> You're going to keep going back to this
and I just gave you the reason why your argument is stupid. So
your answer is no. Shortsighted.
>> Your answer is no. >> The answer has always been
no. I already told you I can't prove a negative. >> No.
The answer has not always been no. >> Yes, it's always
been no. I literally I literally just went off and explained
to you how obviously I can't possibly prove that if you if you
remove something from my vision,
>> No, I just admitted that before this and you didn't
even notice. So don't say gaped when you can't even pick out
the things you think are wins in the same situation 5 minutes
earlier. >> Yeah, five minutes earlier when I saw this
when >> I when I literally when I literally said obviously
you can't prove this. You don't have access to the devices. How
the could you prove it? >> Well, yeah. This is the the
thing. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is like the thing.
This is what I was inevitable. Of >> I mean, you're saying
it's so easy to just like delete messages and fake the metadata
and move it over to a different server and the file. >> That
would be very simple. That would be very simple to spoof the
metadata. Yes. Is very simple to spoof the metadata on
>> You can say that. I don't know. It's not my field. Like
I don't I don't know. Well, I think it's certainly not that simple.
Uh, okay. To spoof the metadata in such a way that it can't be
discovered by plaintiff counsel. Um,
it could be and I'm just not aware of how you do that. I can't
say for sure either way, but I don't think it's that easy. Nonetheless,
there is no positive argument you can make that it's likely that
this has happened uh when Destiny moved his uh Discord logs from
Discord servers to his own,
which is the positive argument that you were making
uh and Queenman was very much making
>> um about a week ago was that spoliation did occur.
You were fighting me hard on that one. You're saying expoliation
definitely did occur because it was >> you're just so we
actually had an agreement on what we were both arguing and now
you've been so thoroughly in this argument that you're actually
just making up a new position for me. Thank you, Tiska.
>> Does this work for you in other places? Are there are
there like a lot of people you argue with who can't track what
you're doing? It's very obvious. It's like so embarrassing.
>> If you say so, bro. >> Weird pseudo intellectual.
I can't lose so I'm just going to make things up now. talking
about just a week ago. >> You literally argued in the same
conversation that I didn't have even close to the same argument
as Queenman. And now you're just arguing that I do have the same
argument you laid out for >> No, I did not argue that.
I did not say that. I said that >> you did say that. Yeah,
you said you said No, you said you were argument was ridiculous.
You're >> tried bringing up Queen a lot and now now your
obsession with Queen has come back to bite you in the ass because
you already put on record you didn't think I had the same position.
>> That's not >> It's so funny arguing with you.
It's so funny every time. It's incredible.
>> If you say so, bro, you got gaped. >> You literally
can't track arguments. It's so funny. >> I think it's it's
it's time you move on to your next segment. So, um >> in
this conversation, just to be clear, you agree that >> dude,
this is so funny to have any >> You should go I just want
you to go back and like slowly follow when the YouTube video
gets posted. If Ral posts this as a YouTube video, I want you
to go back and just slowly follow and watch how you don't understand
what's going on and that you have confidence when you're just
being thoroughly embarrassed on every single point. It will be
therapeutic for you. I promise it will be therapeutic. It will
help. >> It is like a recorded instance of your most maladaptive
behaviors. Like I I hope if you have a therapist, this would
be gold for them. This would be the golden map to fixing all
of your problems. If you have a therapist, you need to give them
this video. Okay? I just I'm telling you it will help them so
much.
>> You do agree that plaintiff
cannot argue or at least
>> cannot make a compelling >> agree to the same
thing I just agreed to
>> You're going to try to disconnect as I say that, but
good luck. You've already failed to to make any sort of edgy
or witty exit. You want to just slink away
>> Okay. So,
you did agree to that. You said that's always been your argument.
It wasn't. You got gaped, bro. Gaped as hell. Gaped as [__]
This was fun. Talk to you
>> Uh-huh. Do get that therapist. So, it's Listen, that's
just free content every single time.
He needs help. He does a little bit. It's
I appreciate it cuz he will come back and he'll do the same thing
like next week and then he keeps paying me for my Patreon. So,
like I I'm just there's nothing but wins here. Good times. Good
times.
Thunderdome chatters, bro. I guess so. Please take me back to
nostalgia land. Is this just you saying
this is Chris? If this is the crisp I think it is. Shut up, Tlesa.
Shut the up. SHUT UP. >> HEY, GOOD JOB.
>> That's the soundboard in the Discord now. Good times.
Give me a second. Pull this soundboard up.
Oh, what the Okay. Well, I think we're out of time, right? Do
we want to If you guys donate, I'd do another video or something,
but if we don't have uh if we don't have any more time on the
clock, if we can't get like five subs in, I'm probably going
to go ahead and do other
I think we have like company over right now, so I might just
go hang out. If if we don't have any donations, I'll give it
five minutes. Let's see what we got. Let's see what we got in
the docket real quick. Real real real quick. Oh, I do want to
watch this Ezra Klein Fuentes thing. the Rob's media guy who's
done a couple like random hit pieces.
He did a video on legal mindset which is very interesting because
he spent all of his time attacking like left leftwing people
and he finally went after legal
Let's go.
Cuz legal mindset, you know, people have to people should be
going after this guy, right? We all know that. We can all see
that. People should be going after this guy. >> Hey everyone,
>> back to Hassan Stark. We could do Hassan China stuff,
too, but I didn't get all of the [__] from that.
So maybe we might do it tomorrow. this guy. So, we got this.
We've got the Fuentes thing.
What else is there? Oh, there's a Jack Dory arrest as well, but
doesn't seem
doesn't seem like we're going to make it tonight. So,
what do we want to do on the way out?
Hassan defends China against anti-LGBTQ
What is this? What is this? Why China block gay dating apps?
I don't think that's true. I think you saw that on Twitter. I
don't know if that's true.
>> Chatter this.
>> Is that Are we getting getting Tisa gifted a sub? Let's
go. Tya,
appreciate the patronage, man. Appreciate the patronage. >> This
is exactly what I mean. If you if you look if you get your notes
from Twitter, which by the way,
like you'll see. We're about to go to Chungdu. What's really
funny about this is like China's gay as hell. Like just watch
the stream
and you will see >> gay as hell.
>> Um like China's gay as hell. You hear the door like
break down 30 seconds later. [laughter]
Wait, did I say gay as hell? Well, I meant not gay as hell. >> Austin's
been on the Austin's been on the apps.
That's so funny. There is like I mean, it's true. Apple removes
Chinese gay dating apps on government order.
Okay, but that's Apple.
Blue and Fina, two of China's most popular gay dating apps, suddenly
disappeared from Apple's Chinese app store. Fanning fear. >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Why were they banned? >> Among
LGBTQ people. Dude, that's Apple. Wait, this happened
>> yesterday. Okay, I'm going to go I'm going to go ask
uh I'm going to go ask people if it's like still available on
because guess what?
You you just can't have gay dating apps on encrypted devices.
Okay, just in case they need to destroy you to to like execute
you later on, they need evidence of you being gay. You can be
gay on a Huawei device so that the Chinese Communist Party can
actually confirm that and execute you whenever they want. That's
all they need. >> Not everything. >> We'll allow
you to be gay on a device we can monitor. That's the rules >> you
read in news. >> And that's not gay, by the way. That's
not so they can watch the videos. That's just so they can prove
it later. >> Media is as it seems is all I'm saying when
it comes to stuff like this.
Especially considering that even the likes of Newsweek, for example,
those are those those apps are super uh
>> Let's go. I didn't want to end, so I wanted to do another
hour, so I'm I'm psyched. Thank you very much, Marty Epste. Appreciate
the five, buddy. Appreciate it. Let's go.
>> All right, we keep going.
>> Those apps are super popular for the record, just so
you know. And I I assume I mean I might be wrong on I might be
totally wrong on this but I assume they they might have done
it for like data related reasons like privacy related reasons
as far as like it's kind of like
I think um Grinder was about to be sold. I get I get why everybody
would accuse him just given Ch sorry given Hassan's
like Chaikcom sympathies for so long. I get why everybody would
go oh he's just going to he's just going to do this no matter
what like this guy. I I get why people would make that assumption
immediately. I I have a hard time holding against people who
want to get mad at him for defending this. I think it's his it's
his obvious inclination. I don't think he's like saying anything
wrong. Is this his obvious inclination?
Bing chilling. Bing chilling. Also, Hassan Hassan. Hassan, why
don't you criticize the Chinese Communist Party? Hassan, Hassan,
why don't you say how this is a disgusting human rights abuse?
Hassan, Hassan, why don't you say how this is a disgusting human
rights abuse in the middle of China right now?
>> uh, there are some people who are just hoping that he
would get like blackedged, right? >> Grinder was about
to be sold to a Chinese company and then they refused to Yeah.
See, Topshi is is correct. We tried to buy Grinder and expanded
to China, but your Congress blocked the sale because they feared
of being outed. Literally, Grinder was supposed to be sold to
a Chinese company, I'm pretty sure.
And uh and the American government literally blocked that deal
from happening because they were like, "No, too many of our dudes
are are sucking on there. Too many dudes in Congress are sucking
on there." >> Dude, what's the deal with that Trump stuff?
By the way, have you guys seen this? Trump Trump blowing Bill
Clinton. What? Have you guys seen this? Have you heard about
this? >> We can't let like the Chinese get back door access
into this. This is a real thing that took place. And I assume
that this is basically the reverse uh
Blocked the grinder purchase to prevent backdoor access. You
hate to see it.
You hate to see it. What's the other
Man upset he's being [laughter] this is a good order I did them
in man upset he's being criticized for spending chi for spreading
Chinese propaganda
thought about it for a brief moment which is
that China is just another country just like any other country
there's good there's bad there's criticisms
that you can make which I do >> okay I all I want Hassan
to do before he talks about China is just think about how he
would feel if somebody made the exact argument he was making
for China
in Israel's defense. Okay? I just I just want him to pretend
in his head if he if he wants to go live and he wants to talk
about China, just when you go to defend, just please, for the
love of God, think about how the things you'd say would sound
if somebody else was saying about Israel to you for the Listen,
man. Israel is just a country like any other country. It's just
there's good, there's bad. Okay. What about the Weaguers? What
about the Weaguers? Hassan, isn't that like an apartheid where
this whole like Arab population is being oppressed? Hassan, Hassan,
please.
>> And also, >> sorry, Arab. I said Arab, I meant
Muslim. I conflate those cuz I'm a >> Oh, there's a lot
of good. The people are great. The the food is amazing. The culture
is amazing.
I am uh very fortunate. I'm very fortunate to be able to actually
experience it firsthand, right? But of course, all the foreign
affairs people
China's cool. China's awesome. We love China. aware of me are
not very fond of my they're not very fond of my my um
China trip. Hassan [__] slowly becoming the new Jackson
Hel doing Chinese propaganda for a living. Insane. Yeah, it's
stuff like this. Oh, apparently that CGTN interview is not good.
I don't know. I don't know that much um like China like anti-enino
or xenophobic propaganda. Okay, my xenophobic propaganda very
low. I wish I could Oh, is my mic out?
>> Wait, wait, wait. What? I thought you guys were saying
true cuz >> it's stuff like this that >> My bad.
>> Uh, I find >> Say my mic was muted. I I just assume
it was this beginning of my mic being muted. Literally just lol
W true. I'm immediately like my mic's muted. My mic's muted.
I I got triggered. Okay, it's my bad. >> So strange because
like
you should be able to go to countries, okay? Like there is no
comparison between China and like Israel for example. You know
what I mean?
Like nobody nobody gives me this much grief when I go to Japan.
[laughter] Okay.
Like
nobody's like, "Dude, I can't believe you've traveled to Japan
and you love
Oh god, this guy's mentality is so stupid. Three people with
almost identical foreign policy stances. Oh my god. Finnish PhD
candidate.
Oh my god. Why is Natse Twitter like this? I mean, it makes sense,
>> dude. I saw this and I'm like, wait, where do these
people have agreement?
The only there's only one place they have agreement, right?
And it's not China. I guarantee Nick Fuentes isn't like isn't
about to do start doing like pro-Chinese propaganda.
That's it's literally just the one issue where they agree. What
are we doing? They're all They're liars. Oh well, yeah, sure,
sure, sure, sure, sure. I mean, they are three white passing
people who do political coverage. They are by definition liars.
Yes. Okay,
dude. I've got this CGTN interview and then what was the original
thing where he gets arrested?
Hold on. Let me let me just go LSF
LSF top of how long ago? Like past week?
Here we go. Here we go.
>> Chinese security police harass the Son [__]
while you streaming live in Tianaan Square.
>> Oh yeah.
>> dude. [laughter]
Why Why would you do this? Just like at at a base level, why
would you have a photoshop of yourself as Mao on a phone on your
stream while you're in China? Like it it's at a base level. It's
like such a it's I assume he just wanted to get arrested or something.
He wanted to get like talked to by the cops. He's on this Johnny
Somali arc or >> Roger. You seen this?
>> Oh yeah.
>> He's immediately uncomfortable. He must see the cops
coming over towards him.
Oh, there's got to be who's got the subtitle clip. Somebody got
the subtit subtitle clip somewhere. His new TSA story. Yeah,
but he doesn't want to do negative propaganda for this government.
Okay. Only the American government.
Only the American government. Can we get uh can we we we got
to have a subtitle version. Chinese Where's Chinese agent? Chinese
agent, tell me what they're saying. Is Chinese agent still in
the audience? Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. a Chinese agent in
the crowd. I need I need a translation stat.
>> Oh, Supreme could translate, too.
>> That's true. That's true.
>> So, you want to see the photo? >> Oh, I didn't
take a photo.
So, have you record anything? >> No, not yet. No.
Oh, I was I was I was holding the camera out, but I didn't do
anything yet.
>> I need I need some translations. I don't know why I'm
just listening to this. Someone's got someone's got subtitles,
right? Nope. Nope.
Whatever. Hassan got pulled over by the cops in China. [laughter]
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I knew if I just
went by top, we'd be getting all We'd be getting all Hassan all
the time. Person in yellow coat is Oh, hold on. This is a newer
Hassan one. Here's the older Hassan one. It's all Hassan. [laughter]
>> What happened with showed up? Um, they were um they
thought so that thing that we went to Okay, hold on. The uh the
flag raising ceremony is not it's not in focus. Hold on. I'm
going fix it. I'm going to fix it. The flag raising ceremony
that we went to
is not a thing that white people normally go to, right? It's
not it's not normally it's not normally something that white
people attend, right? >> And uh >> when did he he
race swapped back to white? Why did nobody inform me that he
race swap back to white? Oh, is this version? We'll grab it.
>> They are probably extra attentive and extra careful
about people coming uh to to you know do some [__]
like there's a reason why for example uh there were Chinese nationals
on uh each other's backs, right? But I knew that like if we did
it, we would get called out by cops cuz like by and large especially
like the government is aware of like how they are perceived or
or how much like you know anti-Chinese probably exists out there.
And I think the older people are also aware of it as well. But
I think the younger populations in China are ironically enough
less aware like the younger normies are are less aware of the
animosity that exists which shouldn't exist at all obviously
but unfortunately does. And it's almost entirely one-sided. It's
entirely designed by uh America.
But yeah, we were we're white. So, as as foreigners in China
at this like national event rather than an international one,
whereas, as you guys noticed, like they didn't didn't have any
like foreigners there at all. Um, he thought he saw something
on the phone. Um, he thought he saw something on the phone like
he thought we were like making a mockery. You know what I mean?
They didn't realize that we were swag [laughter] white boys who
love China. No, you don't understand. I love you guys.
[__] you, White Devil. You white demo. [laughter]
No, I love you. I love you. I love China. I love China. Uh, [__]
you, White Demo. >> Are you being careful with your words?
No, no, I'm just being I'm just telling you like it is.
They thought [laughter] we were they they were being extra attentive
to make sure that you know no one is uh making fun of M or anything
like that or or the ceremony and that's what they were they were
um that's what it was nor police close for make sure that white
people don't do [__] Yeah, it's just a
um yeah it's just it's it's a cultural difference and >> China's
like the one place where you you Okay, not the one place I should
have said something crazy. I was going to say China's the one
place you can't take us on seriously. China's the one place where
like you know how China thinks about like uh Ammerus and like
America first people and how they consider America right in like
every venue. That's how he is with China. Like everything China's
ever done has been correct. He will constantly sweep for China
in every single possible way. You cannot trust anything he says
about China. Even on like a micro level, he he is just like pure
pure People's Liberation Army propaganda at all times.
And also they just don't want anyone to pull a poke ball or anything
like that. How was it resolved? We just like talked to them.
We just were like, "No, that's not, you know, we're not doing
that at all. We're just here to experience the event." You know,
I told you I told you like this time. Yeah. Okay, calm down.
That's not You're being ridiculous. This is actually This is
actually one of the things I want to show Americans in general
cuz like people people have this like false assertion, false
notion that it's uh people have this like false notion. It's
like they will arrest you for a meme or whatever. It's not like
that at all. Okay, calm down. It's funny because like I've dealt
with cops at this point all around the world as you guys know.
Um and uh so as far as like cops that I've dealt with all around
the world, uh you know, European cops in France, American cops,
um [music] just European cops in other European countries and
even Japanese cops as well, I will say that it's not even remotely
up there. The far the further west you go, the worse cops get,
the more aggressive they get. America being the worst one out
of all of them. >> Dude, what?
Hold on.
Wait. I was I was like whatever, whatever, whatever. >> Whatever.
It's not like that at all. Okay, calm down. It's funny because
like I've dealt with cops at this point all around the world
as you guys know.
Um, and uh, so as far as like cops that I've dealt with all around
the world, uh, you know, European cops in France, American cops,
um, just European cops in other European countries and even Japanese
cops as well, I will say that it's not even remotely up there.
The farther the further west you go, the worst cops get, the
more aggressive they get.
America being the worst one out of all of them. >> Okay.
Okay, dude.
I just I don't even Dude, I don't even I just can't even, Dude,
I I can't even. It's Listen, I I don't know why he does this.
I I have no idea why. just totally when he's in when he's talking
about China, he's just totally disconnected from reality.
Like at least at least when American cops at least when American
cops execute you, they go, "Oh, that was a mistake. I didn't
mean to do that." Even if they even if they're totally reckless,
at least at least they're willing to go, "Well, I didn't mean
to do that." In China, you have a video of like your your family
member getting executed and they're like, "We don't have no idea
what you're talking about. That's fake. No investigation. Nothing.
Come on, man.
Come on, dude. Just when he talks about China, yes, he is. I
know you don't want to accept it. He is somewhat tethered to
reality outside of China. All right. But he is completely disconnected
from reality when it comes to China. He is insane when it comes
to China. Completely insane. What?
Ain't no way. What?
Hold on. Quick Hassan break. Uh,
Door Dash delivery girl has been arrested on two felony charges
after recording a man passed out with his pants down in his home
and posting on a Tik Tok during a food delivery. She's being
charged with unlawful surveillance and dissemination of surveillance
images.
Oh, she getting charged, bro. She getting charged. Damn.
I I they're supposed to send an email immediately after deactivation
providing you the re. >> Dude, that's that's actually crazy.
I
>> what the [__] I'm THE VICTIM. REMEMBER,
I'm the victim.
Uh what a what a great summary of that story. Yeah. Yeah. It
was insane for her to post it. It was crazy. It was a totally
insane thing to do. Obviously.
Obviously. All right. Where's Where is the Hassan Stark King
going? Man, do I do I continue on with the Hutch stuff? Maybe
I do. Do you finish the whole
Do we just keep listening to Hutch now? God. Hold on.
Trying to think of where I want to go with this last hour we've
got on the stream cuz I don't I don't know if I've got more China
stuff. Oh, wait. There is one more China thing. Hold on. There
is one more China thing. Oh, I get rid of >> Oh, no way.
is a small one >> person in yellow a yellow code is thrilled
to get a gift of Ma's little red book in China 75 million dead
civilians I okay hypothetically
just real quick hypothetically if you wanted to argue that Hassan
is worse than Nick Fuentes wouldn't you have to argue that Mao
is worse than him and the Holocaust is not unique in any way
that like the Holocaust isn't the worst tragedy ever and like
it's definitely not unique and wouldn't you be like necessarily
arguing that Right. Just hypothetically if you wanted to say
that like Hassan is worse than Nick Fentes by shilling like this.
I feel like you get to go, "Yeah, I guess there's nothing unique
about the Holocaust that has happened multiple times throughout
US history. It's not even the worst tragedy that's ever
I don't know. I be making some claims that most people don't
really like.
>> It's the first version. >> It's the first Wait,
>> Is that a Bible? >> No, that's a little red book.
is
>> don't they deny the mass killings of farmers and land
reclamation is a lie? Probably the Wait, what the
Holy [__] That's Will Nef. [laughter] I somehow couldn't
tell.
Why did he look so weird to me? He looks so odd. His head is
so big. What the His head is like four times the size. We'll
[laughter] nap on some
Will
hours. Okay. Holy [__] those dinner plates. What
is what's going on with this guy? [laughter] >> I'm chat.
>> Oh no. >> Sorry. Started from the top. It >> is
a small one. >> This the first version. >> It's the
first Wait.
>> Is that a Bible? >> No, that's a little red book.
>> It is basically >> the little red book. >> The
little red book. >> It's the red Bible is what it is.
>> Some may say more important than the Bible. Some may
>> especially over here trying to >> Yeah, I know.
No. So, yeah. >> Oh, I think I heard that that lying triggered
a lot of people. Why does Will care about it? I would assume
that Will has very similar politics to Hassan because his wife
has the same politics as Hassan and he's best friends with
right? I feel like that's paint by
I think he just isn't obvious about it cuz he'd rather make money
instead of getting harassed for it all the time.
Seems I don't know. It seems pretty obvious to me. Maybe that's
crazy.
>> Why did he say it like I said it? Get your own Get your
own way of speaking mother. [__] you. Come on. I
I seriously just couldn't bother. I couldn't be bothered to go
find all the Hassan stuff today, so
I I'm just sorting by top. 6'5 golem gets a brutal reality check.
Nope. Still looking. Still looking. Doesn't look like we got
anything else from Assan today. Do we Do we want to see if that
CGTN thing's out there? I'm trying to figure it out. Have you
reacted to Dario calling out H3 from yet? Off topic.
Calling out from H3. What do you mean? Oh, call out from H3.
Oh, no. Go ahead. Send that along. What happened? I didn't know
that happened. Wait, what happened with the Oreo?
Honestly, I'm not really on a topic. I
Today was like disorganized. But
again,
have like two days off in three days and I forget how to stream.
So, overall, not so bad. Could have been worse, believe me.
Was over Teddy glow flashbacklash.
There isn't even anything interesting from his son's China trip
because he doesn't do anything but bounce between coffee shops
and sit in hotel room.
time stamp
hard to see it. [laughter] >> Oh, Jolly St. Nick's in chat.
He said
>> is and and still acknowledge something. I I understand
the statement.
It does hurt to see it. [laughter] >> Oh, Jolly St. Nick's
in chat. He says, "I hope Ela is doing well." >> Thank
you. Oh, is this just where they say support for Nicholas is
pivotal right now or something?
>> Is that all this is?
>> I You know, I love >> I received your message
when you said your message on stream
>> the day that I was the most upset.
>> I love Nicholas Dioro. I'll say it. I've been watching
your content. I think you're very I think you're very funny
and I I feel like your coverage has been really good on topics
that I end up watching. Like you really
>> you're good with research. >> He's the Pope. [laughter]
And I'll say this, Nick, I never thought in a million years I
would ever utter these words. Like if you went back three years
ago or something. I know.
>> I would have never even dreamed that you actually were
talented. One day
I'm just being serious. I always Wait,
Bro, oh, they're up here. They don't realize Nicholas is incredibly
egotistical.
They shouldn't do this at all. They should not have done He should
not have just said that. The only way they could up the free
the free propaganda they get from Nicholas is by doing some [__]
like this. That was an incredibly stupid thing to say. Uh yeah,
I've always thought you were kind of like totally untalented
and a loser, but you know, you're kind of as you sweep for us
hor like as you sweep for us categorically at all times, you
spend all of your effort doing it. Starting to realize maybe
you do have a talent. Be my [__] Be my
Nicholas. That's what you're good at.
Like you really
years I would ever utter these words. >> Hold on. Hold
on. [laughter] Like >> And I'll say this, Nick. I never
thought in a million [__] years I would ever utter
these words. Like if you went back 3 years ago or something.
>> I know. [laughter] >> I would have never even
dreamed that you actually were talented.
>> I'm just being serious. I always like >> I'm just
being serious. Like I'm just being serious. Like I I kind of
thought you were a total loser, but you're actually pretty good
at
me off publicly for a job, Nicholas. That's what you're pretty
good at. You're pretty good at being my [__] Nicholas.
coming along and sucking my dick whenever I ask Nicholas. That's
what you're pretty good at. That's I'm just saying I probably
would feel weird if somebody I was helping out was saying like
that. I' I'd personally feel weird. Nicholas, maybe he's into
that kind of thing. We'll see. >> He was quickwitted. I
mean, even though we had different opinions. Yeah. >> Yo,
Marmadude, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. >> Uh,
you know, back then I felt like >> he was always good on
his toes. I never really tuned in to be fair, but >> I
avoided because I I knew these people don't like us. So, I just
never even watched anything >> just for sanity. >> I
totally avoided everything. >> Um, which is like the same
reason I don't open the snark surve or whatever. >> Oh
my god, dude. >> Also, to be fair, Nick used to participate
in some really nasty stuff like calling Ela horse face and stuff.
That being said, water under the bridge, but I'm just saying
there was a reason. >> Yeah. But he thought that I wouldn't
um forgive him or anything, but I actually watch your content
pretty regularly now. >> I think I really like I like Dioro.
I got to say I got to admit it. I'm a Dioro fan. >> You're
setting him up though now cuz now >> this is bad luck.
>> He's going to turn on me. >> Something something's
going to happen. You just every time we endorse >> someone
always hated that piece of
>> dude. The way the way Ethan said that.
I think this is like the way Ethan and Nick are connected is
they both have incredibly fragile egos.
Like shockingly fragile egos. I
Ethan should think about how he'd feel somebody said that about
>> More like the popper
broke beggar. You like that reference? That was a good play on
words. >> Pope and the popper.
>> Probably do poppers drug addict. Anyways, nice to see
you, Nick. Um,
>> beat him up with peace and love. What shirt is Ethan
wearing? I need it. Are you talking You're talking about the
jacket, I assume. >> Probably. That's >> I saw lots
of people commenting on the jacket last time I wore it last week.
Yeah, it's on the website. It's um >> it's really beautiful.
It's got this lovely texture. It's warm.
>> The details are beautiful.
>> I think it's
I think you'll love it if you do buy it. Um where is it? >> Okay.
All right.
I'll be honest. I don't follow any of this enough to super care.
It cries a lot about people refusing to work with her. What did
she even do? I have no idea. I saw like some stuff around this.
I straight up like don't give a [__] about these
people.
Like I I'll be real. I could not care
They seem to be doing really well though, so that's good for
them, right? 456,000
views on this stream. That's like a massive stream.
Maybe they're Maybe they're up big.